11 días han pasado y los familiares de
los 10 mineros que quedaron atrapados en
una mina en el estado de coahuila siguen
sin tener noticias de sus seres queridos
denuncian que los trabajos de rescate no
han avanzado como esperaban y que las
autoridades han evitado dar respuestas
concretas sobre el estado de la
operación se miran trabajando muy
seguido como deben de ponerse
salen a comer y duran de las 2 horas
descansando descansar mucho
ese es el problema que tiene la gente no
nos dicen no sale nadie a decir nada
durante la última semana las autoridades
y los equipos de rescate han estado
bombeando agua fuera de la mina para
permitir a los rescatistas entrar en las
cámaras pero durante la madrugada del
domingo ocurrió una inundación que
retrasó el rescate de los trabajadores
en efecto los rescatistas solicitaron
más ayuda para que los expertos puedan
descender a la mina nos ayude más
extranjera de donde sea pero que nos
ayuden que dejen bajar a toda la gente
que
está capacitada para esto los mineros
quedaron atrapados en el interior de la
mina de pinabete el pasado 3 de agosto
cuando sus trabajos de excavación
provocaron el derrumbe de la pared de un
túnel y posteriormente la inundación de
tres pozos